the way you get respect as a woman is by
being feminine there's nothing we can be
equal and very very different I'm not
saying that when there's not equality
but you've confused equality with the
same you can be equal with completely
different things you can have a bishop
and a knight on a chessboard they're
equal in terms of points but they do
different things right a woman can have
equal respect to a man if she is very
good at being a woman and a man gets
respect for being very good at being a
man when a woman decides she wants to
act like a man or a man wants to act
like a woman that's where all gets
up we're trying to pretend it's
all the same it's not the same men and
women are good at different things we
have different strengths different
weaknesses there's nothing wrong with
accepting that there's nothing wrong
with saying I'm a woman I'm good at X
he's a man who's good at why then we
work together as a team we have a
beautiful family we're happy forever